In Japan, over 3,700 passengers aboard a Japanese cruise ship have been quarantined,...
...due to the possibility of coronavirus onboard.
A university laboratory in Lyon, France, is researching treatment for the coronavirus...
...by utilizing existing drugs.
In Iraq, Prime Minister-designate Mohammed Tawfiq Allawi...
...spoke on Iraq's recent protests and violence...
...and alluded to not being able to form a new government if the clashes continued.
In Ukraine, a fight broke out between lawmakers in the Ukrainian Parliament...
...while debating a proposed law that would allow the sale of the country's rich farmland.
Finally from Turkey, three are dead and 180 injured...
...after a Turkish plane failed to land correctly and skidded off the runway,...
...splitting into three parts at an airport in Istanbul.